I thought this was really interesting a
study came out at Pew study saying that
Millennials are becoming more and more
unlike their parents 50 percent of
Millennials are self-described political
independence 27% said Democrat and 17%
said Republican almost two-thirds don't
classify themselves as a religious
person and only one in four Millennials
is married almost half of the baby
boomers were married at this age so the
political end of that that doesn't
really surprise me in any way I mean
people are just so sick of politics and
now for all the other topics that we've
been talking about the show with all the
ways you can get information now we're
just endlessly bombarded with this
nonsense out of our political system so
that shouldn't surprise us right I was
reading this article and I felt like he
did this because of me because I felt
like it you are how old are you
20s twenties which qualifies as a
millennial I think yes
okay fair fair I am above the Millennial
age I will put that out there yeah
you're a millennial I am I you know I
mean I spent a lot of time with
Millennials I grew up with them I think
that I think that unfortunately a lot of
the the hyperbole that we sort of exude
with our BuzzFeed mentality and our kind
of lackadaisical attitudes it's not a
stereotype it's true I mean a lot of
people are very entitled and it's
obnoxious it's easier for people who
aren't entitled now because like there's
not as much competition I'm just talking
abut Millennials as a whole compared to
our parents generation as far as
marriage goes it's really marriage in a
church right I mean obviously a lot of
my friends are getting married now I
mean even more than I think that I would
expect and probably I mean being from
Indiana more than out here certainly but
I will say that if you've ever been to a
wedding you know that a wedding is about
getting drunk for the most part and it's
a lot more fun to be drunk in a lot less
fun rather to be drunk at a church than
it is to be drunk at a Shakey's Pizza
parlor in Irvine I'm just saying you
know what I mean wow really [ __ ] on
these
city of marriage boy and Shakey's does
anyone get married at Shakey's I'm not
sure but let's look at a graph comparing
the different generations so the percent
who considered themselves politically
independent and you can see the way way
higher millenials Generation X that is
my generation we're a little bit below
the boomers just a tiny bit below
Generation X which does surprise me and
32% of the Silent Generation identify as
political independence and on the right
side percentage of adults in each
generation who are religiously
unaffiliated and again Millennials are
the highest Gen X boomer silence so that
all sort of makes sense is this just
evolution of thought in a free country
that people will get away from Dogma we
just did the story about 13 countries
where you can be put to death for
atheism so in a free society you're
going to stray away from that kind of
stuff I think so because just from my
point of view I don't affiliate myself
with a political party and I never have
I if I get married I don't know if I
want to I don't actually want to do it
in a church and a lot of it is wanting
to not want rejecting dogma and wanting
to think on your own and have your own
thoughts like for instance I voted for
President Obama in 2012 it's not I don't
sit necessarily agree with everything he
does in fact I openly disagree with a
lot of things he does but that just
seemed like the better alternative at
the time I don't want to necessarily
abide by Democratic Dogma or
Presbyterian Dogma or anything like that
I want to be able to consider these all
by myself yeah so I don't want to make
this too much about politics but as part
of this that the Republicans really
aren't that different anymore and it's
all about big money and business and we
know all that
so people vote for things that they
don't you know you're just most people I
think actually are voting for the lesser
of two evils yeah and you're really not
doing much yeah I don't know I mean I
think like when I think about when I
went to high school and I got edumacated
it was with a bunch of other Millennials
and we really didn't have a very robust
sort of political program you know I
mean it was kind of like I think a lot
of people maybe don't they just feel
disingenuous disenfranchised by the
process and especially with you know the
way things have been people's approval
ratings from Washington are so low we're
less interested in sort of the political
or the religious kind of fundamental
fundamentals yeah do you think when we
talk about these generational things and
they're really not quite generations
because the millennial generation right
now is 18 to 33 that's not quite a
generation of people but do you think
that that age range is too big because
if you're say thirty right now you have
a huge discrepancy in your life and
you're an adult in living a life
hopefully with a job and independently
rather than an eighteen year old it's
it's a really big gap well do you think
it's more of an age gap like you those
eighteen year olds will eventually be
similar to the thirty year olds when
they're at that point in their lives or
do you think they're actually have a
divided and thought ah well that's a
good right so I guess that well that's
the question
do they suddenly shift out and start
thinking like the generations when we
get older right so it's also part of
this that people have more liberal views
when they're young and then suddenly
what what happens I never understand you
start paying money you start paying
taxes they're paying more taxes than you
were before and especially if you're
self-employed you know you start
realizing how much of your money that
you've you you know put on the table it
gets taken away to pay for things that I
think that you maybe don't really feel
benefit you at least that I think
historically has been it obviously I
think we're probably a lot more socially
aware than then maybe we were in the
past but you know the other thing is
really horrible for the Republicans is
like is the abortion and the gay thing
you know they just it's just for someone
in my generation it's just an immediate
turnoff
I think I think no you can't get past
that even if you like the the the
economic policy of sort of more limited
government you just you just can't get
behind somebody who's so you know some
people maybe us included that there
wouldn't be equal rights for gay people
that their abortions would be illegal
things like that and it just you can't
get around it
right there's
it's sort of being a big part of that
right so that being said 2016 when the
you know we're gonna have to wide open
you know I guess Hillary's already been
anointed Queen but we're gonna have two
races at least two primary races is
there gonna be one Republican that has
the balls to say I'm okay with Kay
equality and I don't love abortion but I
don't want to make it illegal well there
be one of those twelve dingbats that get
on stage and say something like there
has to be or they are I don't know if
they'll survive yeah I thought so the
only one that they had in 2012 that sort
of did that was John Huntsman and he was
basically laughed out of the camp yeah
and unfortunately he also he was a
Mormon you know and you see how that
turned out
right for MIT that's right it's right
but still it's just blasphemy I think
you know geez if somebody's able to
communicate like why you would be a
Republican if you're not a religious
sort of zealot then I think that's
really powerful but I just don't see it
happening because a the name is so bad
it's like it's like bang man just drag
it through the mud yeah every single
time and you know I think a lot of
people's hearts in my generation we're
really libertarian you know we'd like
the idea of freedom but we just can't
get behind the the religion part
[Music]